"Order the following pizza
for the Taskmaster
without using any of
the following words."
"Extra large pizza
with pepperoni,
peppers, pepper..."
"Pineapple, tuna, and dill."
"Most accurate pizza order
and vocabulary wins."
"Also, you get an extra point
if you can make the pizza person
say the word 'bubbles.'"
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Man: Yeah.
Thanks for calling Johnny's.
May I help you?
Hold on.
It's Lisa.
How are you?
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
We're going to see Lisa,
Freddie, and Ron, first of all.
-Okay. We're a team.
-Yes.
Woman: Hello?
Hi. How are you?
Good. How are you?
Doing wonderful.
I was wondering
if I could place an order.
Okay.
What would you like?
Man:
Lou's Pizza.
Afternoon.
How are you doing?
Good.
Wonderfully.
Yeah, nice -- nice day.
Beautiful, uh, weather.
[ Laughter ]
You know,
it's the perfect time for,
you know, ordering
what you need.
Yeah, man.
Listen to me.
You know the round
things you sell?
They're made out of dough
and sauce and cheese?
Man: We have a calzone,
but it doesn't come with sauce.
The flat thing.
What's the biggest size
you have?
-Extra large.
-Okay, I'll do that.
Then what's the
biggest you have?
-Large.
-No, it's not.
Can you make mine
a little bit more big?
I'd like a very big one,
please.
-What size?
-The biggest.
[ Line hangs up ]
Hello? Hello?
[ Laughter ]
He just hung up on me.
Like, I want the --
I want --
I'm sorry.
I don't order that many pizzas.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Light laughter, groaning ]
What kind of pizza toppings
do you have?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Audience groans ]
[ Line rings ]
-Hello?
-Hi. Hi there.
I think we got cut off.
Can I order the pizza?
Is that all right?
[ Buzzer ]
-Extra tomato, green pepper.
-I think that one.
-Pepperoni, sausage --
-That one!
Wait!
What's the first one?
-So you what toppings?
-Okay. Shh!
-Do you want --
-You run through them.
I'll just say, "Yes, yes, yes."
Okay. Go.
[ Line hangs up ]
Hello? He hung up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Could I have a Hawaiian one
without the ham?
What would you put in
instead of ham?
-What do you want?
-A very -- Something very...
Sorry. I've just
forgotten the...
[ Line rings ]
They're not even answering now.
They, like, blew me off.
-Johnny's. How may I help?
-Just one last question.
[ Chuckling ] Do you have
any fruit that you put on top?
Type of fruit? No.
[ Line hangs up ]
[ Laughter ]
Just sprinkle on a little bit
of, um, salt and thingy, the...
Man: What?
Salt and --
and its [Chuckling] friend.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Please give me one food item.
Do you want me to take that
to the shop?
[ Laughs ]
Go.
-Thanks, Lisa.
-Bye.
00:02:48,502 --> 00:00:00,000
[ Cheers and applause ]